fractures in the relationship between
President Trump and Director of National
Intelligence dan coats were sometimes
exposed in public and in real-time hey
we have some breaking news the White
House has announced on Twitter last
summer it was an American journalist who
broke the news to Coates that the White
House had invited Russian President
Vladimir Putin to Washington not the
president that moment left Americans
wondering who was in charge of the
sprawling collection of 17 intelligence
agencies including the NSA and CIA there
were concerns raised when Trump named a
political loyalist Congressman John
Ratcliffe as coats's replacement seeming
to value loyalty over experience we need
somebody strong that can really rein it
in because as I think you've all learned
the intelligence agencies have run amok
but Ratcliffe got a lukewarm reception
in the US Senate that would have to
confirm him when his resume was found to
be lacking
he was drew Trump lling the media as I
felt that congressman Ratcliffe was
being treated very unfairly I was
reading the press critics say Trump's
demand for loyalty is eroding the
ability of intelligence officials to
properly do their jobs they're supposed
to provide unvarnished assessments but
that's not always what the president
wants to hear agents will be much more
reserved in their efforts to carry out
these kinds of investigations both with
respect to mr. Trump other politicians
because it does open up this hornet's
nest
Trump's second choice for DNI named on
Twitter is retired Admiral Joseph
Maguire a decorated Navy SEAL who
currently heads the National
Counterterrorism Center
now as acting director of the DNI he
inherits the unenviable task of
delivering intelligence Trump has often
disagreed with including whether North
Korea will abandon nuclear weapons
escalating confrontation with Iran and
Russian interference in u.s. election
what's unclear is whether Donald Trump
plans to formally nominate Joseph
Maguire to be the Director of National
Intelligence or if he sees the post as
temporary given Trump's demand for
loyalty and McGuire's reputation for
offering unvarnished intelligence
assessments
Kimberly Hellcat al Jazeera the White
House